all right so need to share some news a
decision has been made and Dan will not
be returning to the game dance pillow is
officially out of Survivor Island of the
idols it won't be coming back to camp he
won't be on the jury he's gone on
Wednesday's episode The Hollywood talent
manager was removed from the competition
following a claim of inappropriate
touching toward an unnamed person after
the show ended a title card read quote
Dan was removed from the game after a
report of another incident which
happened off camera and did not involve
a player survivor contestant Kelly Kim
was the first to raise concerns that Dan
was being too touchy dan has been
extremely inappropriate day one gray
refused to sleep next to Dan like
literally everyone's like Kelly doesn't
like touching people you know I don't
like touching people because Dan kept
touching me following the news that Dan
got the boot
Kelly shared this statement on Twitter
which read in part quote while Dan's
dismissal has validated the concerns
that I raised from the beginning of this
season I wish that no one else had to be
subjected to this type of behavior even
yesterday he was like took my hair and
like went like this like kicking a
little I'm like don't touch my face
Kelly took her concerns to survive our
producers there are always consequences
for standing up this happens in real
life and work settings in school like
you can't say anything because it's
gonna affect your upward trajectory it
can affect how people look at you and in
a rare moment for the CBS reality show
they broke the fourth wall and told her
he was given an official warning you
know if there are issues things need to
happen yeah come to me and I will make
sure that stops okay
I don't want anyone filming dance exit
marks the first time in the show's
history that someone was removed from
the game for inappropriate behavior
earlier in the season Dan was accused of
unwanted touching by three women on the
show like it made all of us
uncomfortable like this isn't just one
person it's a pattern but later two of
the women admitted to exaggerating the
allegations in order to get him voted
off the island
the original VOC I are not the biggest
fan of Dan and so if I can play up that
card and whatever way possible I'll do
it in a joint statement to ET at the
time CBS and MGM said all contestants
are monitored at all times the statement
also claimed that Dan was given a formal
warning in a new interview with
Entertainment Weekly the show's host
Jeff Probst open up about Dan's initial
reaction when he was told he was
removing him from the game he was not
happy we talked through everything for
quite a while and by the time he got on
the boat to leave he had calmed down and
was actually very respectful as he
departed Jeff added quote above all we
want to ensure that all players always
feel safe and respected et has reached
out to Dan for comment